the jurogan experience we get to the
same place in healthcare how the hell do
we fix this i mean i ca i can tell you
what's wrong okay but how the hell do we
fix it and we fix it with exactly the
solution that you've proposed that the
constituencies that are affected need to
move into positions of power in society
so we've got the constituencies are
the doctors
who are not getting good information
they think they are but they're not
and the doctors got to understand that
this is a very serious problem and that
they're trusted to be learned
intermediaries to
apply medical science in the service of
the patients and they can't do it under
these circumstances and we've got
businesses non-health care related
businesses that are paying a fortune for
their health care and losing their
competitiveness and they should be in on
this and most of all we've got consumers
who want the best health
but in order for each of those
constituencies to become
competent political activists they've
got to understand what's going on
and right now they don't they don't and
this uh this term that of uh
diseases of despair is very accurate
right like if you look at
like west virginia
and you look at these places where you
have these
pill like tremendous pill problems
this is this is what's going on there's
these people that really don't have
anything to look forward to
and this is what alleviates some of
their horrible feeling is to just get
drugged up and the drug companies were
very willing to make a buck doing it
yeah have you ever seen the um the
documentary the oxycontin express no
it was on vanguard um
and it was uh essentially they showed
that
florida had created this situation where
they would have these pain management
centers
that were essentially just pill mills
the pain management center was connected
to a pharmacy that only
had pills they only served opiates so
you would go to this pain management
center you go to the doctor and you say
doctor my back is killing me the doctor
said what you need is some oxycontin son
and they would write you a prescription
you would literally go right next door
and they would have the pills for you
and they also did not have a digital
database so you
could go to jamie and get a prescription
from jamie and then leave him and then
go to another doctor mike right down the
street and get a prescription from him
and you could do it all day long and
people were doing this and then they
were selling these pills on the
oxycontin express it drove it straight
up into kentucky and ohio and you know
wherever the highway took it and they
they were seeing how there was a direct
chain of events where these people were
going to these pill mills stockpiling
all these pills and then they were
selling them into these other states and
making a lot of money right so you see
the synergy between the folks whose
lives aren't working out the way they
wanted to and they're miserable and
maybe they're miserable because of back
pain or maybe they're miserable because
life doesn't have the meaning they hoped
it did and you have the drug company
which is telling doctors that they've
got a new product that's less addictive
it's so much less addictive that you can
treat non-cancer pain and not get into
trouble with it
then it lasts 12 hours but they know it
doesn't last 12 hours and when it wears
off before 12 hours they tell the
doctors to increase the dose because
that means they're not taking enough not
that their drug doesn't last 12 hours
right
and and that it can't be abused and
people are crushing it and putting in a
straw and shooting it up and
so forth so you've got the drug company
that's an actor
and you've got the social circumstances
where people are hurting whether it's
medical hurting or spiritual hurting or
whatever you want to call it
and it's just a recipe for disaster and
without the appropriate oversight of the
drugs
we're not
the faucet the spigots turned on
and that's in this country has been one
of the most egregious offenses by the
pharmaceutical drug companies is
distorting the data on the
addictive properties of opiates
absolutely
it's a scary thing when you think you
find out how many people there was a
statistic that was just
revealed uh just released rather that
from people 18 to 49
uh
fentanyl was the number one cause of
death a hundred thousand people
died in this country from fentanyl that
are ages 18 to 49
extremely potent opiate yeah and most of
it recreational right most of it is like
from cut all of it yeah it's hard i
don't know if it's 100 i think it's 100
000 deaths total and fentanyl is a major
proportion of those hundred thousand
deaths oh that's not what i thought i
think i thought i saw that it was they
were literally attributing a hundred
thousand deaths they were saying it's
the number one cause of death between
people age 18 to 49 which is insane that
we're not hearing about this because
it's such a large number of people like
this should be something that's on the
news every day it should be something
that terrifies folks yeah actually
that's the way you said it
say it again it's the way he said it oh
so what is the actual number the way the
headline reads is uh so the drug
overdose death top a hundred thousand
annually for the first time driven by
fentanyl also it's all kinds of drug
overdoses but drug overdoses are the
number one cause of death between people
18 to 49. but but joe
here's the problem
drug overdoses are the number one cause
of death
but that accounts for only a quarter of
the excess deaths
in that age group
what are the other three the other three
quarters are
the
cardiovascular disease diabetes
cancer
and
that's the problem is that we do such a
poor job in the united states
of preventing preventable disease
were last amongst developed countries in
preventing preventable disease